here to present some oscar-worthy snacks
is a woman who deserves
a thunderous standing ovation because
she's my partner in culinary crime
chef
i look amazing no that outfit is
everything do you mind taking a turn
also please show it off
pockets it's amazing
the last time we got dressed up was my
45th birthday
a very long picture of that really and
um
it's such a pleasure to have an
opportunity
to be festive with you guys absolutely
all right laura you have three snacks
that anyone can make for their viewing
party and of course
they have a special oscar-themed name to
each one
i love these names ross please introduce
our first snack
okay well they are the la keith
steak-filled taco cups in honor of
lakeith stanfield who's nominated for
best supporting actor
for judas and the black messiah how do
we make these they're really easy to
make
you take a wonton and you cut them out
and then you bake them off for 12
minutes
and they're these little nifty edible
parcels
today we're doing them steak filled so
we have some grilled steak in them and
then we're going to put a little bit of
a dollop
of some crema sauce which is just some
sour cream and lime and garlic
and then you're going to top it off with
a little pickled red onion so it's like
a little taco you can fill this actually
with anything
you like like grilled corn salad a
little fish salad
i love these at a party because they are
like absolutely shall we
i've had these first of all i'm elevated
i'm seriously salivated
[Music]
okay that crema is so bright it's that
lime mm-hmm
what's that exactly and then you have
the crunch from
the little wonton cup it's really really
satisfying it's delicious
one bite i can probably eat a hundred of
those in one go the award for
best appetizer go shoot below all right
ross
reveal our next one up next we have
maria bakalova
baklava you know the best supporting
actress nominee and one of today's
guests
tell me how you made this one so baklava
is a traditional middle eastern dessert
and it's usually phyllo dough and
chopped nuts and honey and all these
wonderful flavors
we shrunk it down and talk about
little cheat i used store-bought phyllo
dough so that makes it super easy
and then you just take chopped
pistachios chopped walnuts some honey
some cinnamon some butter
and they're these beautiful little one
bite things so
ready
[Music]
and then it has a little cinnamon a
little cardamom and some rose water
which i know you liked
they are a little sticky because they
have a little date in them which gives
them
sweetness so that holds like the whole
thing together
at first i was like is it a raisin no
it's it's a date i love
dates they're my favorite all right ross
what's our final snack
you keep chewing sasha baron cohen is
nominated for best supporting actor
and we have a sasha borson cohen biscuit
i love biscuits any excuse to eat a
biscuit i'm like i'm down
and these are great because you can make
them ahead and freeze them
and then you can bake them off like as
you need them they're perfect for a
party
and so on the side you can garnish with
chives we have more bourson cheese for
you
okay or you could do a little drizzle of
honey or all of the above
what are you thinking drew how beautiful
the fact that you can taste the borson
in the biscuit yes
but you don't just need to spread it on
top
okay these are incredible i'm i
i literally want to do this which is
just crazy
do it thank you for bringing such
beautiful food to the party it really
elevates
the whole experience i mean you guys for
having me
i'm in a like a toss-up right now i'm
like do i shove the
steak-filled taco or the boris and
biscuit
these are my dilemmas
you